there she is and now that we've
established that Katy Perry and Thomas
Rhett are here Katie sangeeta's got a
question for you
and that whole thing with the eyelash
the the robot movement thing you did
like all these different theories
eyelash glue have you seen it Thomas
right now
I'm showing them I like have all these
party tricks
thank you
I would always watch my makeup artist
doing my face okay I'm watching you do
my brow and then I'd switch I just I'm
afraid
if one thing's more certain about all of
the theories is I am afraid but
something that's not so freaky Katie and
Thomas's collab hit where we started
[Music]
she doesn't know who I am up under sick
of me saying this but it's the truth
when Katie hopped on the song like it
literally took it from like good good to
amazing getting to have done it on
American Idol was such a dream come true
[Music]
getting to perform at the Saint maze is
going to be I'm really excited and while
we're all so excited to watch Katie and
Thomas perform at tonight's CMA Awards
the duo opened up about their instant
bond and when you guys created this
video that was the first time really
meeting each other and I understand you
guys talked about Parenthood because
that's the first thing we all do right
is talk about our kids there were
multiple times filming this video where
they were like all right guys we're
ready for y'all and we're like Defender
just like showing pictures of our kids
no one tells you about the first six
weeks of having your first child
and you're like feeding in the same
corner of the same room for six weeks
straight and you're like will I ever
leave this house